almost two decades and he still comes
how you doing buddy brought you your
favorite candies come on boy you got get
over her
Mary Samsonite was just a girl yeah wait
a minute so you mean you have been
faking for twenty years and it was all
for a gag yep that's awesome
Oh once you roll me inside we'll get the
nurse to take the catheter out me we
don't need nurses for that but don't you
have to I like what you've done with the
place who's this
oh that's butthole I found him out in
the alley why did even butthole cuz of
this good name totally fits the postcard
from fraida felcher Harry I'm pregnant
please call me what do you think it
means Harry boy look at the postmark
1991 I had a daughter
I gave her up for adoption
[Music]
what if we go track her down you're hot
for my daughter what am i right or am i
right
[Music]
[Music]
allarakha Allah
[Music]
I know she'll appreciate all the trouble
you've gone to to find her let's call
her whoever this is we're in the middle
of something very important here this is
your dad
what hey guys I know this is weird
timing but I gotta take this
it's my dad dad she's got me on hold
we've got the diamonds
Mikey's listening they're underneath me
did you hide them inside this Turkey
yeah just above the giblets no timings
in here and you're not my grandson
Harry she's got me down you can cross
that one off your bucket list
[Music]